وعلى فكره اخي احمد هذا الحزن وهذه
النظرات او المشاعر الاسنه
مهم مهم جدا بالنسبه للكتابه الشعريه
بالخصوص الكتاب
الفرح قليلا ما ينجح في انتاج نص شعري او
ادبي جميل
خاصه في الوطن العربي الى مائه هذه
الاشياء تعطي قيمه همم نوعيه وقيمه مضافه
همم الفرح جميل ايضا واحساس جميل ونريد
دائما ان نكون مختلفين
بانفسنا وباصدقائنا بالعالم من حولنا لكن
قل ما ينجح الفرح في انتاج
دائما ينتجه
والنص العظيم ينتجه الم عظيم اجمل الموتور
الادبيه في العالم شعرا وسردا انتجه الالم
انتجتها تراجيدي الانسانيه
والعنف الذي نواجه والعنف المادي والرمز
ايضا ليس هناك فقط العنف المادي العنف في
الافكار
كيف ان مثلا يعني الفكر الغربي المتمركز
على ذاته لا يقود الانسان من حاله المتوحش
الى حاله الانسان كما قال ادورنو يقودنا
هذا الفكر الغربي من المقلاع الى القنبله
الانسان والسلام والعدل والمساواه
على الورق على الورق يبدو ما في ما في
نجاه انه الانسان يعني يحقق انسانيته بشكل
ما في امل هذا الامل دائما موجود هو الذي
يعطينا الحق ويعطينا الاحساس بضروره
الاستمرار لكنه امل يائس كيف ننجح في ان
نجعل هذا الامل املا
هنا السؤال